the lakes and forests in southern Sweden
Smolin Regent its pristine nature
in between our villages where time seems
to stand still it's a world right out of
a picture book that's no wonder because
some very famous children's books are
set here in and around the small town of
vimy booth they're the stories of
Swedish writer astrid lindgren
the author was born in bin abou in 1907
some of her stories are set even earlier
I spit hot if she just wrote different
stories set in the time of her father
for example and they go back about a
hundred and fifty years Danny sassette
Susskind hundred and fifty shava these
times are brought back to life in Astrid
Lindgren swirl a theme park on the
outskirts of vim abou the settings of
Lindgren's books are replicated
according to descriptions in her stories
well mohammadi national here we bring
the fairy tales to life we turn them
into reality here the children be
different characters from nine or so
books bijan the most famous the cheeky
red-haired girl Pippi Longstocking
theatre performances are held all day in
the park during summer rain or shine
other characters like a meal in lüneburg
ax appear and rania the robbers daughter
is there to meet children and parents
alike the childhood memories for me as
well that's where and come to come visit
if it's wonderful it's the legacy of
astrid lindgren and it's it's good
stories for all ages it's not just
children's stories that testify to the
imagination of smolens inhabitants so
too does the glass art from the glass
Rickett or kingdom of crystal glass
blowers started settling here in the
17th century smolin resident balouch dad
explains why this poor heavily wooded
area became a glass center it took
enormous amounts of wood to heat the
furnaces where you make the gloss so
that was one important reason and you
also had the sand around here too which
is the main ingredient in gloss so you
could take the sand from the nature you
could take the wood and heat the
furnaces the glass hutton trans fuel is
one of these smallest factories shared
by several glass blowers master
glassblower mariana degner and lars
goldberg are working on a multi-layered
multicolored base small and glass
attracts a million visitors each year
yet the industry is shrinking it's so
very special for for these parts and
only a few glassworks exists these days
formerly there were something like a
hundred or so in in small on but today
they're only well let's say five or
something like that
the oldest still in operation is the
glass manufacturer in Costa a town with
a population of 1,000 it doesn't just
create art but practical glassware
that's sold around the world the
glassblowers use traditional methods
which take years of training most of the
people who is left here I started here
not at school today you can go with less
cool that when I started we started as
apprentice and work their way up the
cost of Eau de art hotel is considered a
jewel it's modern glass art has been
attracting tourists since it opened in
2009 the hotel's cobalt blue glass bar
is an experience in itself
and the pool is likely the only one
worldwide where glass fish Bob in the
water and treasures made of glass can be
found at the bottom and so it's a
mixture of fantasy tradition and
pristine nature that attracts visitors
from around the world to small end
you